In this lesson, we've learned about four really
interesting traits, and the concepts we've discussed can
actually be summarized into four main points. Point
one, variations in single genes are responsible for
many different kinds of traits. Point two, mutations
can be either loss of function or gain
of function alleles. That are either dominant or
recessive, depending on the molecular phenotype. Point three,
an individual mutation can be dominant or recessive depending
on the trade perspective from which we're viewing it.
And, point four, knowing your carrier status for a
genetic trait or disease, can be a very personal decision.